so yeah they want to groom your kids
but they're grooming them for
annihilation
we know that many teachers in this
country are groomers but the question
about groomers that isn't asked often
enough is who grooms the groomers in
order for teachers to groom children
effectively they must first themselves
be groomed and this means that those of
us who wish to uncover expose and put an
end to the grooming epidemic in public
schools have to dig a little bit deeper
to answer this question
see where it starts because if we simply
call out the predator teachers then
we're just pruning the branches of this
giant hideous tree we're not getting to
the roots that's what brings us to the
latest expose from journalist chris
ruffo who alerts us to a recent
conference advertised to and attended by
teachers in the philadelphia school
district
the conference as rupaul reveals
covers such topics as kink bdsm trans
sex and quote
banging beyond binaries
oh and the conference was open to
children as well rufo reports quote in
early july 2021 the district office of
diversity equity inclusion sent
invitations to the philadelphia trans
wellness conference to teachers and
staff on the sdb sdp connect mailing
list promoting the conference as a way
to quote learn more about the issues
facing the trans community the
conference was organized by the mizoni
center an lgbtq
activist organization that has worked
with the district on sexual education
programs when reached for comment the
school district of philadelphia
described its promotion of the
conference as part of its commitment to
creating equitable and inclusive
environments and said that it did not
have any information on the number of
teachers who attended the event sure
they didn't
now we have some video from this
conference that we're going to play for
you um much of it cannot be played
because it's so relentlessly graphic
that i'd have to
bleep pretty much the whole clip but
before we play them you need to realize
that this non-profit the mizoni center
it is it's influential well-funded
entirely within the mainstream of the
modern left
and speaking of its funding last year it
received five million dollars in
government contracts
that is according to its own financial
disclosures by far and away its greatest
single source of income it only made
about two to three hundred thousand
dollars in donations another 150 grand
in grants and then 2 million from the
paycheck protection program
so this is an organization
propped up and funded by the government
and used to indoctrinate government
employees who then turn around and
indoctrinate our children
and also as referenced at the mizoni
center they create
sex education programs which are then
used in schools
so what are they all about i mean what
do they teach
for that we turn to some of this footage
which is i warn you
extremely disturbing and gross
but also important that we see some of
this and we start with a seminar with a
trans activist talking about prosthetic
penises and quote masturbation sleeves
let's watch
the purpose of this workshop is to
showcase different types of prosthetics
available for sex almost every single
one that i will be showing you all of
them actually look like penises
i have tried and touched many
all right prosthetics real
all this is one of the most realistic
feeling in terms of like the inside of a
penis all right now a pack and play is
going to be a prosthetic that you can
use
for sex but you can also pack with it
when you're not having sex you're just
walking around it's your everyday packer
that you just wear in your pants and
then when you're ready to get in the
mood you have boy
and you can go and have sex
but here
that it's a big boy this is like
gigantic all right
give me
give me two hours alone and i'll get
this in my butt you know
that's a
government-funded workshop
for teachers
a government-funded workshop
for teachers
now why would teachers need to know
about dildos and prosthetic penises
in order to do their job teaching
children the groomer claim is a
homophobic conspiracy theory we're told
if that's the case then why is the
philadelphia school district
suggesting that his teachers attend a
deviant sex work workshop
there's a whole grooming thing it's not
happening
this is everything you're seeing right
here none of this is happening it's not
actually happening
it's just your imagination
another class was titled transects
banging beyond binaries and here's how
the host and leader of that session
introduced
i think it's herself
impossible to tell anymore but
introduced herself
and i'm also um a pretty big
i'm a and i and i i wear that title
pretty proudly um
and i self-identify as kinky and
polyamorous
and
um
and i also call myself an organizer
because in my free time outside of my
day job i like to get people together to
explore
their fantasies and
um their perversions in groups
hi i'm lucy fielding and my pronouns are
she they please mix them with reckless
abandon
i am a
resident in counseling in practicing in
charlottesville virginia
i am also a sex educator and um i'm a
white
queer
kinky polyamorous
um
visibly able-bodied
jewish witchy um non-binary trans-fem
now it's difficult to select just one
thing for this distinction but perhaps
the most disturbing part of that clip
is that the self-described white queer
kinky polyamorous visibly able-bodied
because that needs to be added now to
your
list of identities jewish witchy
non-binary trans femme is a counselor
and that's not a quirk or a coincidence
by the way the counseling industry seeks
these types out
which is why the entire field must be
i'm afraid to say distrusted and
discounted
by the way later in the same session
they shared some thoughts about more
inclusive terms for body parts that the
teachers could learn and of course bring
into their classrooms
so let's uh let's hear some of those
suggestions
so this is how the game's going to work
is that we're going to drop into the
chat different words that we like to
hear for
bodies
um that are not gendered that are like
completely
just
fun names
for
people's bodies
like
a great one just as an example just to
get it going and then you all can
jump into the chat is um
i like
people to use the word
goodies
can i touch your goodies
i feel your goodies
thank you to sierra
that
that was uh
introduced to me back in middle school
yeah
chest and front and back hole are great
too
front and back hole um quite a romantic
way to speak i'm sure that'll get people
in the mood
and there's much more footage along
these lines and worse as roofo reports
the conference began with presentations
promoting puberty blockers hormone
treatments breast removals and genital
surgeries in one session which was
titled the adolescent pathway preparing
young people for gender affirming care
by dr scott mosser
the principal at the gender confirmation
center in san francisco explained that
he has performed over 2 000 top
surgeries which which involve removing
girl's breasts that there's no age limit
for beginning the gender journey quote i
do not have a minimum age of any sort in
my practice
he said explaining that he would be
willing to consult with children as
young as 10 years old with parental
consent
in another session open to children
gender affirming masculine and
feminizing hormones for adolescents and
adults dane menken divisional director
of lgbtq services at mainline health
endorsed treatments ranging from puberty
blocking hormones to manual breast
binding for masculinizing adolescent
girls he said quote i'm a strong
proponent that you can bind for as many
hours a day as you can tolerate binding
now all this is horrifying of course
especially uh ten-year-old
ten-year-old girls
at his practice where he chops breasts
off of
girls he would he would accept a uh a
quote patient as young as ten
now all of this of course would have
been considered far far left obscure
crazy fringe stuff
only just a decade ago or less
now it's being taught to teachers in
philadelphia at government-funded
workshops
and everything said by these people is
obviously disturbing
disgusting and morally debated but i
would like to focus on just on just one
statement made in the first clip that we
played
the woman as you recall
embraces the term perversion
okay that's the term she uses
she openly says that she encourages
people to explore their quote
perversions
that's a very important choice of words
because the word perversion
literally means
corruption that's what the word means
when something is perverted it is by
definition being taken off of its
original course it's being distorted or
corrupted taken away from what was first
intended for it this is the dictionary
definition of the term perversion
and that's what this is all about
that's what this conference is intended
to do corrupt the teachers so that they
may corrupt the students
we talk about children being groomed
what we actually mean is that they're
being corrupted
this is in fact the left's entire sexual
agenda in a nutshell so to speak and
because it's their entire sexual agenda
it's also their entire agenda period
their whole their whole world view
revolves around sex they see nothing but
sex
everything comes back to sex there's no
removing sex from education as far as
they're concerned because they cannot
remove sex from anything that's why when
you say this well why can't you just
educate the kids without all this sex
stuff
it does it doesn't even compute
they cannot perceive
um anything outside of sex
everything comes back to that for them
these are the ideological progeny of
alfred kinsey after all and he was a
psychotic deviant who said that everyone
else was a psychotic deviant just like
him and he believed that everyone was
sexual from birth and that everything
was sexual that there was no way to
separate sex from anything
his disciples believe the same
but their sexual agenda just like their
agenda in every other area of life
it doesn't seek to to build or or create
anything
new it doesn't even we talk about how
they want to normalize this or that and
that's i i think that's not exactly
the right word
because they actually want a world where
nothing is normal there is just the
concept of normalcy doesn't exist
what leftism seeks to do is destroy
simply
and leave the ruins to sit there and
decay
and it does this in a very literal sense
to human bodies it chops the breasts off
of girls and leaves them to live with
the scars mutilated and broken
how will this help them how will it make
them happier
what are they supposed to do now i mean
you chop their breasts off you take a 10
year old girl
and mutilate her
what you're supposed to do now
well nothing doesn't matter to the left
all they want is to to take everything
that is whole and true and natural and
normal
and just blow it to smithereens
it is a movement of destruction
especially sexual destruction
so yeah they want to groom your kids
but they're grooming them for
annihilation
well i hope you enjoyed that clip from
the matt wall show if you did go ahead
and hit that subscribe button right down
there so you can stay up to date on all
of our future content